un bon dessin vaut mieux qu'un long
discours
et bien moi je vous dirais ils votent
encore mieux un bon discours avec
quelques bons dessins depuis quinze ans
que je fais des dessins de presse et des
animations cartoon je suis émerveillée
par l'effet produit sur un public par un
petit dessin posée au bon moment dans un
discours on n'apprend pas ça à l'école
ou alors si peut-être dans une certaine
mesure
moi quand j'étais à l'école et que je
m'ennuyais je dessinais dans le fond de
la classe et puis plus tard dans le fond
de l'amphi probablement inspiré par le
cours est certainement par la bande
dessinée belge des années 70
ça nous faisait rire s qui avait le plus
de succès c'était les caricatures de
profs mais comme vous pouvez vous en
douter
j'avais parfois des rappels à l'ordre
aujourd'hui plus de rappels à l'ordre
on m'invite pour faire ça c'est devenu
mon métier ça s'appelle l'animation
d'événements par des dessins en direct
vous même dans vos organisations ou
participer à des séminaires des congrès
des présentations de produits des
remises de prix alors convenons-en c'est
parfois long protocolaire ennuyeux et
bien un cartooniste peut dynamiser tout
ça avec des petits dessins et un esprit
pour l'occasion un peu rebelle il est
planqué dans un coin de la salle avec sa
caméra ils écoutent ce qu'on dit il
cherche des idées bien sûr si on s'est
un peu préparé à l'avancé
c'est de l'improvisation quand il a une
bonne idée il a dessiné le plus vite
possible et un moment opportun
c'est-à-dire entre de diapos d'une
présentation entre deux intervenants ou
simplement la fin d'une phrase boom
il envoie l'écran ce qui amène un peu de
légèreté ce qui fait réagir sur scène et
avec un peu de chance tout le monde
rigole voilà où ça peut mener de
griffonner dans le fond de la classe de
se moquer de ce qu'on dit ma foi un
comportement qui n'a probablement pas
les faveurs de la pédagogie mais c'est
quand même devenu ma profession et
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas désagréable
vous avez compris que ce type de
performance est destiné à rythmes et un
événement de façon originale afin de
maintenir l'attention du public
mais qu'est ce qu'on observe en premier
lieu c'est qu'une atmosphère positive de
détente s'installe dès l'annoncé de la
présence d'un dessinateur humoristique
les gens sourient et se disent ah on a
aussi pensé à notre bien-être
cet effet est renforcée si le
présentateur et les premiers
intervenants
le chef par exemple se montre réceptif
par rapport au dessin et montre
l'exemple en quelque sorte
il est de bonne humeur aujourd'hui le
chef d'ailleurs si rigole nous aussi on
peut rigoler au bout d'un certain temps
le public a compris et il est un peu
conditionné et il s'attend à un dessin
après chaque intervention ou une
caricature de chaque intervenant
on me confiait la semaine passée et
c'est tout à fait authentique saran
addict eh oui au fur et à mesure les
gens changent leur manière de penser
il anticipe les gags il ya de l'humour
dans l'air et cet état d'esprit est une
des clés de la tension
à condition de ne pas en abuser je crois
aussi que face à un dessin nous
retrouvons un esprit plus enfantin -
analytique plus réceptifs et c'est
probablement à ce moment là qu'on peut
espérer toucher les consciences avec des
messages porteurs de valeurs humaines
mais je constate déjà que la moitié au
moins d'entre vous ne m'écoute pas parce
que il attend la suite du dessin c'est
ça que je vous disais ça rend accro et
c'est le seul bémol de la soirée
il n'en faut pas trop des petits dessins
parce que si ça stimule la créativité
ça peut en revanche entraîné une paresse
intellectuelle face à un public
multinationales comme c'est de plus en
plus souvent le cas on constate ainsi
qu'un accueil généralisée bah oui pour
beaucoup qui ne sont pas de notre
culture associée réunion sérieuse et
petits dessins sert à quelque chose
d'extravagant
alors ça me fait plaisir parce que quand
j'envoie le dessin je vois les appareils
portables se lever pour prendre des
photos ça montre à quel point le cartoon
est universel
d'ailleurs tout le monde aime ça vous en
connaissez beaucoup vous des gens qui
j'aime pas les dessins humoristiques
n'ont d'ailleurs vous même je suis sûr
que quand vous ouvrez votre journal la
première chose que vous regardez c'est
les petits dessins et après une
animation
quand on reçoit les évaluations des gens
ce qu'ils sont appréciés en premier dieu
merci c'est des petits dessins juste
suivi de la nourriture mon père dit
toujours vite et bien ne vont jamais
ensemble
eh bien je n'ai jamais été d'accord avec
cette idée là d'ailleurs quand j'étais
tout petit je rêve est dessiné très vite
et c'est utile parce que ce que le
public apprécie en premier lieu c'est
l'esprit d'à propos
c'est la vitesse de réaction ainsi vous
pouvez avoir un dessin facile si vous le
placez au bon moment dans un discours
vous pouvez espérer faire rire toute la
salle
prenons l'exemple d'un orateur qui ne
parlent pas assez près du micro
comment lui dire de façon courtoise par
ce petit dessin que j'ai toujours dans
ma trousse de secours selon - le dessin
humoristique va plus loin que les autres
médias
et c'est un phénomène bien connu dans
les rédactions un article de journal
doit observer des critère de véracité
d'objectivité de pondération une photo
de montrer la réalité sinon c'est un
trucage
c'est de la diffamation en revanche on
tolère qu'une caricature par une
représentation imaginaire montre un
point de vue beaucoup plus subjectif
plus militant plus engagée plus
subversif et c'est salutaire
moi aussi en direct j'ai l'impression
que je peux faire dire ce que je veux un
personnage orateurs comme public
présentateur un jour un patron d'une
société d'assurance après une fusion
parlait de cohésion de collaboration
travailler tous ensemble mais moi dans
le fond j'avais mère j'avais remarqué
que ça commençait à bavarder lors jean
veil ce dessin j'ai dit tout le monde
doit travailler ensemble pas parler
ensemble bon exemple facile j'ai pas
choisi un exemple qui demande une
demi-heure pour planter le décor enfin
ça vous montre qu'on peut être utile
tout en passant un message
une autre fois c'était un manager qui
sur un ton monotone tenter de dynamiser
ses équipes il fallait intervenir
fallait intervenir bon j'ai envoyé ce
dessin c'était une façon de lui dire une
façon positive de lui dire tu as une
belle voix mais tu nous ennuie alors le
le type en question il a très bien réagi
sur scène il a dit ok message reçu et il
est reparti avec une nouvelle énergie
donc on s'est un peu moqué de lui mais
au final ça l'a servi alors ça c'est
quelqu'un qui après son spi tu viens
chercher son dessin bah oui quand vous
vous retrouvez dans une illustration
même assaisonner vous vous sentez un peu
illustre ça vous fait plaisir vous le
prenez comme un cadeau c'est là qu'on
voit que le dessin contribuer à la
popularité interne de ceux qui ont osé
venir prendre la parole alors
quelquefois tel chef lui même qui vient
me trouver et qui dit avec moi vous
pouvez y aller ne vous gênez pas c'est
génial je suis invité pour me payer la
tête de mon employeur c'est qu'il a
compris évidemment qu'un peu
d'autodérision va servir son message où
son image bien cette expérience me
convainc d'une chose c'est qu'un petit
dessin humoristique peut à lui seul
porter l'information importante
l'information de haut rang je dirais
même pour quelqu'un qui veut se
distinguer que c'est un adjuvant
privilégié de toute communication
sérieuse et efficace
pourquoi est ce si efficace nous allons
entrer un peu plus loin dans l'analyse
nous allons disséquer le cartoon les
outils tout d'abord un petit arrêt sur
le terme cartoon qui nous évoque
généralement les dessins animés le
cartoon c'est le dessin en une 15 ou le
message prime par rapport à la forme ce
qui compte avant tout c'est l'idée le
cartoon va droit au but voilà pourquoi
est il si efficace en premier lieu par
sa forme visuelle qui dans le débit des
informations écrites ou prononcés se
démarque un manque ablement c'est que
l'image nous parle directement
elle ne nécessite pas un code et c'est
très anciens trains songer aux peintures
rupestres charge caverne avec des
animaux disproportionnée songé à tout
les civils
a sion laquelle n'a pas sa culture
graphique pains tous sculptés avant que
décrire l'homme dessinait c'est un art
primitif
ensuite il y à l'exagération
le terme caricature vient de l'italien
carricart et qui signifie charger dans
le sens d' amplifier ce qu'on cherche
avec ce style de dessin c'est
d'amplifier un élément du discours de la
pensée qu'on veut illustrer
ensuite il y a la simplicité
d'ailleurs c'est simple quand on exagère
quelque chose c'est au détriment de tout
le reste
le cartoon va droit au but tant pis pour
les nuances et pour cela il faut
également une forme très simple rapide
désinvolte la plus perméable possible à
l'idée ça rejoint mon quatrième point
l'humanité d'une part le cartoon et
volontairement un parfait on sent sous
le trait est un peu maladroit voire mal
dessiné la personnalité de l'artiste
c'est tout le contraire du texte
typographiées et c'est tellement plus
chaleureux au fond quand quand c'est pas
parfait
d'autre part il ya presque toujours des
personnages dans les cartoons ce qui
humanise toute la communication
alors on aime on n'aime pas on
s'identifie on se distancie bref on
communique quel est le cinquième point
quelqu'un a une idée un mot bien c'est
l'humour bien sûr le cartoon et vecteur
d'humour qui provoque en nous le sourire
ou le sourire intérieur le rire dans
toutes ses couleurs à la la ça c'est un
autre sentiment ça ça nous remue de
l'intérieur ça nous propulse dans un
état de bien-être qui favorise lui aussi
l'attention la réceptivité et c'est bien
connu des dragueurs l'envi de collaborer
forme visuelle exagération simplicité
humanité humour rien que ces cinq
aspects puissant en eux-mêmes génère en
nous des émotions bien plus que le texte
ou le discours quand une information est
associé à des émotions elle reste bien
plus longtemps dans la mémoire et je
n'ai pas besoin de vous faire un dessin
la mémorisation la rétention formation
est un début mais de la communication
bien vous voyez que c'est un moyen
rapide très efficace pour communiquer et
j'espère qu'avec ce petit topo je vous
ai donné envie d'utiliser le cartoon de
le rechercher de le faciliter
et puis pourquoi pas vous même essayé
essayé de dessiner je suis sûr que vous
en êtes capables j'ai quand même un
petit message un petit clin d'oeil
particulier aux éducateurs aux
professeurs face à un tempérament comme
le mien
à présent terminée j'aimerais tenter un
dessin dont j'ai eu l'idée
quelques jours après attentats du 7
janvier 2015
alors on commence par un personnage un
peu effrayant donc on va lui faire
immédiatement un grand sourire voilà
qu'est ce qui tient de ckoi 5
une petite mitraillette ou une
kalachnikov pour les connaisseurs on va
détaché le bras de la silhouette parce
qu'ici il ya la chaîne de balle
entre temps on va lui écarter les jambes
c'est beaucoup plus marrant et la botte
foule à réussir d'un coup la deuxième
jambe est un peu cachée très important
les lacets ça donne un effet de bottes
militaires les petits dessins toujours
on y revient mon second personnage un
peu plus petits les yeux mi-clos le
regard débonnaire de trois quarts dos
puisque le premier trois quarts face
quelques plis ici up
qu'est-ce qui tient dans sa main 1 1
voilà on va lui mettre quelques armes
aussi commencé à comprendre les gens va
parquet c'est plus dynamique
enfin plier plutôt une des baskets bien
dans le sol on va pas faire de
différence 1
alors vous voyez je vais pas je vais pas
tout remplir sinon je vais effacer la
silhouette et puis ça donne des petits
reflet comme ça j'ai oublié son ventre
tout à l'heure c'est pas grave
des reflets ici on à la botte qui est
plus large
enfin grandir celle là alors ça donne
une vision assez mike et manichéenne ça
vous montre en fait le temps qu'il faut
pour réaliser un dessin à partir du
moment où on a l'idée un petit rappel
ici je pense prône le temps une
kalachnikov ya du bois ici il ya du bois
la cie renseigne l avance voilà j'ai
même le temps de lui faire un pantalon
militaire
j'ai eu quelques touches de couleurs ici
alors il est temps de salir un peu le
dessin parce que c'est un peu statique
tout ça on va le faire un peu plus
méchant nain
excusez moi
merci de votre attention merci